los haitianos enfrentados a una crisis
humanitaria
la escasez de combustible obliga a
cerrar los servicios de los hospitales
casi por completo
y simplemente ponemos el generador por
la noche o cuando hay una cirugía y
hemos detenido las radiografías las
ecografías
es un gran no hay luz en la sala de
maternidad
aquí las mujeres dan a luz a sus hijos
durante el día
la red eléctrica es poco fiable por lo
que los hospitales dependen de los
generadores eléctricos que funcionan con
diseño las poderosas pandillas de puerto
el principio que bloquearon el acceso a
los depósitos de combustible para exigir
la renuncia del primer ministro ariel
and rey tienen en jaque el sistema
hospitalario y el transporte estas
organizaciones delictivas hacen parte de
las mismas que este mes secuestraron a
17 misioneros canadienses y
estadounidenses
sólo soy un conductor de motocicleta no
sé cómo usar un arma no bebo no fumo
porque mi hijo necesita oxígeno es por
el gobierno haitiano la policía los
criminales es un problema grave aunque
este viernes dos camiones aprovisionaron
dos mil galones de dice en el hospital
de la universidad estatal de haití el
combustible no es suficiente las
organizaciones empresariales critican la
supuesta pasividad del primer ministro
casos hospitales del país se van a
encontrar con grandes dificultades si no
encuentran el combustible que necesitan
para tener electricidad
para poder atender a los enfermos
a la espera que el problema se solucione
las calles de haití y caracterizadas por
el bullicio seguirán en la tensa calma
debido a la escasez